il a une centaine d'années et fait plus
de 3000 pages c'est le code du travail
depuis plusieurs mois le gouvernement
prépare sa réforme
l'objectif simplifiée et assouplir pour
ce spécialiste du droit du travail
il s'agit d'une nécessité l'entreprise a
changé l'entreprise n'est plus la même
que dans les années 60 70 et 80
aujourd'hui on a une mondialisation des
échanges on a des entreprises qui sont
dans un environnement économique
extrêmement différents diamètres 20 ans
en arrière parmi les 131 pages du projet
de loi une connerie des journées de 12
heures et des semaines pouvant aller
jusqu'à 60 heures sont envisagées des
mesures dans le viseur des syndicats
déjà existantes notamment dans les
hôpitaux mais de manière très
exceptionnelle selon benoît petit elles
le resteront
même si le texte était adopté en l'état
il est évident que sur un certain nombre
d'orientations comme par exemple la
modification des taux de majoration des
heures supplémentaires ou sur
l'augmentation de la durée de travail
etc
on y lit est toujours un accord
d'entreprise qui soit la condition
préalable à ce type d'évolution de rien
ne se fera non plus sans l'adhésion des
organisations syndicales qui négocient
ces différents accords ces mesures ne
toucherons pas à l'âme du code du
travail et c'est pourtant ça que benoît
petit juge nécessaire de modifier
il défend un modèle de cogestion
d'entreprise à l'allemande ou salariés
et employeurs décident ensemble dans un
certain nombre de sujets le projet
actuel n'évoque pour l'instant rien de
cette piste la présentation du projet de
loi en conseil des ministres aura lieu
le 24 mars